I'm delighted to be able to introduce
the Varkey foundations
surprised last year my brother spoke
about some
the qualities of those teachers who have
had the greatest impact on young lives
he said the best teachers are those who
can reach young people early in their
learning journey supporting them often
through turbulent times in their lives
to give them the best chance for the
future I would like to build on what
William said by highlighting the vital
role teachers also play as our role
models in addition to reading writing
and arithmetic the very best teachers go
beyond the pages of textbooks to teach
young people about determination
aspiration resilience and of course
compassion we will all face setbacks and
challenges in our lives and our teachers
play a vital role in preparing us for
those ups and downs the finalists for
this year's global teacher prize are
from every corner of the world from the
Canadian Arctic to Kenya and Pakistan
but there's one thing they all have in
common they spark curiosity within a
child and nurture the dreams that can
change our world for the better I'm sure
everyone can remember the teachers who
did the same for us and those that
helped us through our forwards of years
I can certainly pinpoint those who had
an impact on my life our foundation is
proud to partner with charities like the
Varkey foundation who are helping to
create brighter futures for the next
generation I would also like to thank
His Highness Sheikh Mohammed bin Rashid
Al Maktoum for his continued support of
the teaching profession and the
patronage of this prize
I'd like to end by congratulating all of
the finalists you are not just
exceptional teachers you are the role
models who support inspire and shaped
children's lives your work is so
important and I don't believe it's an
exaggeration to say that you're shaping
the future you're all winners in my book
and more importantly your students books
you